[Crowd, in unison:] 'Good Morning John, it's Friday!'
Obviously, LeakyCon was amazing. I'm just talking, right now, a little bit so that I can use some clips 'cause I'm not gonna make a whole clip video but:
clips, clips, clips, clips, clips.
So in 2007 I wrote a song about Harry Potter that changed my life.
And I made a promise to myself, because that was such a momentous occasion in my life,
that I would write another song about Harry Potter every year on the anniversary of that video.
And I have done that, but this year I have saved my song so that I could release it on the stage at LeakyCon.
And now I've done that, and so I can release it to all of you.
If you don't like Acoustic Hank, or even Singing Hank, then you can skip 'cause there's important stuff at the end of this video.
♫ There's a place where I always wanted to go through a platform at the station. Well, I think you know. ♫
♫ It always seemed so much more beautiful than here, but things are not always quite how they appear. ♫
♫ 'Cuz  I've done a little searching and become concerned that the wizarding world isn't quite what we had learned. So I'm gonna share a few of those fears. ♫
♫ This is an open letter, to the Wizards of the UK, 'cause I've finally got the nerve to say the things that I've gotta say. ♫
♫ You make it seem like your world is so pristine. When its Angels vs. Demons it's not hard to pick a team. ♫
♫ Well I used to want to go to Hogwarts too, but now I've got a couple questions for you. ♫
♫ Well, you don't seem to have much industry. Wizards work at schools or the ministry. ♫
♫ And by letting Goblins house your currency, you're letting them control your whole economy. ♫
♫ I don't understand how any business gets done, when a wand only costs 7 Galleons. That doesn't seem like much to me. ♫
♫ This is an open letter, to the Wizards of the UK, 'cause I've finally got the nerve to say the things that I've gotta say. ♫
♫ You make it seem like your world is so pristine. When its Angels vs. Demons it's not hard to pick a team. ♫
♫ Well I used to want to go to Hogwarts too, but now I've got a couple questions for you. ♫
♫ They say you can put a stopper in death... Well I'm wondering why you haven't shared that yet? ♫
♫ 'Cause when my friends and family die, and the wizards aren't helping, well I wonder why. ♫
♫ You can make new hands and regrow bones. Dumbledore is 150 freakin' years old. ♫
♫ And I don't think we'd mind if you shared. ♫
♫ And your isolationist tendencies, they truly worry me. With the Dark Lord at your doorstep, you hadn't called for help yet. ♫
♫ You've got known racists playing politics and slaves making your food. Yeah, SLAVES making your food! ♫
♫ Yeah, I don't think its as nice as it appears. I think I'd rather deal with the problems we've got here. ♫
♫ Which is why I wrote this open letter, to the Wizards of the UK, 'cause I've finally got the nerve to say the things that I've got to say. ♫
♫ You make it seem like your world is so pristine. When it's Angels vs. Demons it's not hard to pick a team. ♫
♫ Well I used to want to go to Hogwarts too, but now I've got a couple questions for you. ♫
♫ Yeah, I had a couple questions for you, and that's why I sang you this tune. ♫
Done.
There's another important date coming up very soon which you may or may not know about.
If you don't, I can't really talk about it 'cause there's somebody watching who we can't... we gotta, just keep it on the DL (down low).
There is a one time only use mailing list that you can sign up for and you need to do that by Saturday night because that is when we will be sending the email out.
If you wanna help with this thing it's not a lot of work, and I would really appreciate it. Dooblydoo.
So that's all. Oh, right, I forgot ab-- I forgot about you. Its, its a llama elephant. Its a puppy-sized llama elephant.
Who am I kidding? Its ♫ French, the puppy-sized llamaphant! ♫
John, I'll see you on Tuesday. My voice is still so croaky.